Sonntagabend-Blues, ich sitz im Zug, gestehe mir ein, die Flucht ins Wochenende, findet jetzt ein schroffes Ende, morgen wieder sechs Uhr dreissig auf der Matte, es beschleicht mich Mulm, das ist ein mulmiges Gefühl, ein mulmiges Gefühl.
Doch dann zum Glück denk ich an mein Geheimrezept, es sind Stefan und Florentin, vor denen seit Jahren meine Sorgen fliehen. Ich wünsch euch viel Vergnügen, die beiden werden lügen. Doch es ist ja nur ein Podcast, der keinen Anspruch auf korrekte Darstellung paläontologischer Forschungsergebnisse erhebt. Oder Damien, man weiß es nicht genau, Damien, Damien, schön, dass du uns beehrt hast mit diesem herrlichen Gesang. Müsste man da zuschreiben, finde ich, wenn es Damien wäre. Was ist aus diesen Accentigü geworden, aus diesen Akzenten, hat Deutsch nie übernommen, einfach mal zu sagen oder mal einzelne Buchstaben groß zu schreiben, auch innerhalb des Wortes, um zu wissen, ah, in die Richtung geht's. Ja, was ich ja spannend finde, ist bei Hoäcker, dieses, diese drei Punkte auf dem E. Ah, das hat es halt auch schon mal dieses, wie heißt es. Wie heißt es noch? Ja, Trigema. Trema. Trema, ach krass. Wow, du warst nah dran, ey. Das haben wir erst vor hundert Folgen besprochen, du weißt es noch so gut. Ja, ich weiss noch, als wäre es gestern gewesen. Ich glaube, die Folge hieß sogar so. Also die beiden Punkte über dem E in Hilfsmittel, das anzeigt, dass die Buchstaben O und E getrennt ausgesprochen werden, nicht als Ö, Höcker, Hoäcker, Tremer. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Ja, gibt es ja bei vielen so Patrick, Patrick und dann so, ja, wie soll man das jetzt sagen, woher soll ich das wissen, würde man jemanden korrigieren, wenn er es falsch sagen würde. Wobei man tatsächlich bei meinem eigenen Namen, da muss ich natürlich hart mit mir ins Gericht gehen, denn natürlich in meinem Passausweis steht, wir alle wissen, Florentin David Pascal, aber die Geschichte dazu ist, dass jeder Teil meiner Familie dürfte sich einen Namen überlegen, meine Mutter natürlich als Hauptnamensgebung Florentin, mein Vater Programmierer nach der Programmierersprache Pascal und meine beiden Brüder nach ihrem damaligen Idol David Hasselhoff. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das heißt, technisch gesehen müsste ich eigentlich David Pascal heißen. Aber ich meine, letzten Endes sollte ich ja die Hoheit darüber haben. Das heißt, David, ich meine, ich benutze es sehr, sehr selten. Die Idee war, die Brüder dürften sich was aussuchen, Mutter, Vater dürfen was aussuchen, alle Namen werden. Es gibt kein Veto--Recht. Weil sonst wäre David auch nicht der dringend. Nee, nee, nee. Aber ich glaube, meine Eltern haben sich schon gut entschieden, dass zwei Brüder nur einen Vorschlag haben. Dass nicht die beiden, jeder von denen auch noch. Ja, genau. Weil dann heißt sich irgendwie David Zelda oder irgendwie sowas. Blauer Power Ranger Pascal. Aber nicht so schlecht eigentlich. David, das finde ich ein bisschen uncool jetzt, dass du nach David Hasselhoff benannt wurdest. Ich überlege einfach, ob ich nicht die nächsten 30 Jahre meines Lebens dann doch wieder in Richtung David gehe und dann die letzten vielleicht zu David oder so nochmal irgendwie so eine ganz exzentrische Geschichte. Pasquale. Pasquale oder sowas nochmal richtig rumdrehe. Aber Florentin schon einfach wegen auch Florenz, oder? Eine Liebe zu Florenz? Keine Ahnung. Weiss ich nicht, was da vorgeht, bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Aber die anderen Hintergrundgeschichten kennst du ja auch. Die Programmiersprache Pascal.
Ja, aber meine Mutter hatte keine Erklärungsnot. Das war einfach so, nee, so passiert das jetzt.
Also das war ganz klar, auch hierarchisch, ganz eindeutig, dass man sagt, nee, da wird nicht hinterfragt, da gibt es keine Erklärungsnot. Namen klingen immer ausgedacht.
Ja, okay, gut, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Das möchte ich mir so im Raum stehen lassen.
Weiter.
Namen klingen ausgedacht.
Hat sich irgendjemand dasselbe ausgedacht, einfach so einen eigenen Namen?
Nee, die sind ja schon entstanden, immer aus Gründen.
Aus einer Liebe zu einer Stadt zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich.
Stimmt, so wie Städte heißen, heißen dann alle in der Stadt, hießen so, und damit sie
sich dann irgendwie ausgeteilt haben,
und alle hießen dann Florian, Florenz
oder Roma.
Roman. Roman. Roman.
Der aus Rom. Roman, römischer Mann, der Mann aus Rom.
Roman. Wohingegen Sven,
einfach daher kommt, habe ich noch nicht gelesen, von Junge.
Sven. Sven.
Junge. Ich mache vor, das ist Junge.
Das sind die unkreativsten
Eltern der Welt, die einfach sagen, Junge, ja, aber es wird Junge, Sven. Ja, nicht bei uns. Wikingern werden Kinder, höchstens zwölf. Okay, jeez, jeez, okay. Okay, jeez, jeez, jeez. Rudine, meine Damen. Das kann ich auch anpassen. Aber das ist schon nervig, der Name für Autokorrektur zum Beispiel. Flötenton, ja. Wenn man Flötenton will oder Bernadina bei mir. Wirklich? Ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt. Ah, war ich auch schon. Ja, das ist interessant, weil die Autokorrektur ja immer überlegen muss, welche Teile sind genau falsch geschrieben oder ist alles falsch geschrieben? Ich glaube, genau, meiner denkt, ich habe alles ein Buchstabe auf der Tastatur daneben falsch geschrieben. Aber könnte Bernadina sein. Es gibt ja so ganz viele Kalibrierungssachen, wenn du ein neues Gerät hast, neuer Monitor oder so. Eigentlich sollten da auch die Finger gescannt werden. Wie dick und krumm sind sie, wie hart muss die Autokorrektur, weil die Autokorrektur sagt, ich habe keine Infos. Ich habe nichts, ich habe nur den reinen Text und muss da irgendwie was entschlüsseln. Gebt mir mal ein Bild von dem Menschen, der schreibt einfach.
Nur als Grundlage.
Die Hände, sowas.
Sie wollen die Autokorrektur einrichten, ja?
Fortfahren?
Ja, okay, fortfahren.
Ich würde gerne einfach Programm starten.
Ich muss nämlich kurz eine Mail schicken.
Für die Autokorrektur müssen wir ein paar Dinge über Sie wissen, als Mensch, damit wir einschätzen können, wie Sie Sätze meinen.
Okay.
Schreiben Sie A, immer alles gross.
Was ist B? Weiter. B, schreiben Sie das mit zwei S oder einem S. Ich muss ein, weiter. Warum beantworten Sie diese Fragen nicht? Weiter. C. Schreiben Sie nach Name, nee, Entschuldigung, schreiben Sie … Was ist denn das für ein Betriebssystem? Schreiben Sie nach sehr geehrter Herr oder Frau, den Briefanfang groß oder klein? Uuh, klein. Eher klein? Eher klein, ja. Sie können wählen zwischen eins, immer klein, zwei, manche klein. Ich schreibe eher klein, ja, ja, ja. Können Sie machen, wie Sie wollen. Ach so, okay. Neigen Sie zu all caps? Ja. Neigen Sie dazu, die das-Regel zu beachten? Nein. Neigen Sie in casual conversations zu richtiger Rechtschreibung? Ähm, immer außer Rhythmus. Ich sag schon mal, mein Problembereich ist Rhythmus. Buchstabieren Sie das Wort Rhythmus. Ach komm! Jetzt wird es einfach zum Spellingen. R-Y-T-H-M-U-S. Du kannst auch fragen, ich soll es in einem Satz benutzen, kannst du auch sagen. Können Sie Rhythmus in einem Satz benutzen? Ja, der Satz ist, wie schreibt man Rhythmus? Cool, danke. Kann ich eine Definition haben? Rhythmus. Naja, sowas wie ... Okay.
Aus welchem Land kommt, aus welcher Sprache stammt das Wort?
Griechisch.
R, Y, T, H, Y, M, U, S.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ja, wenn es jetzt wirklich aus dem Griechischen kommt, dann flippe ich hier aus.
So viel haben wir noch nie Fortschritt gemacht in einer Folge. Ey, vor allem, ich habe heute zufällig das Finale des aktuellen Spelling Beasts gesehen. Alles Griechisch. Yes! Alter, wir werden immer besser. Man muss sich nur einfach tief in die Rolle eindenken, und schon weiß man das alles. Von wegen Introman, wie war der Name nochmal? Damian. Dam, wir lügen nicht, wenn wir sagen auch die Wahrheit, aus Versehen. Ich habe das Finale des Spellingbeasts gesehen und es war ganz spannend, weil am Ende sind es nur noch zwei Kinder, es sind immer Kinder und nur noch zwei Kinder. Und Peter Griffin manchmal. Nur noch zwei Kinder und es geht ja so lange, bis einer ein Wort verhaut. Also die schaffen ja die allermeisten richtig, die sind ja super schlau, aber es geht immer darum, uns eins zu verhauen. Und das Wort, an dem die Finalistin gescheitert ist, war Stimmungslage. Ach, deutscher Spelling Bee? Ja, nee, nee, international, englisch. Und das deutsche Wort? Das deutsche Wort Stimmungslage. Ja, aber Leute. Nee, Bewusstseinslage. Nee, Entschuldigung. Stimmungslage. Bewusstseinslage. Also auf jeden Fall ein Wort, das man auch als Deutscher nicht wirklich benutzt. Es war ganz merkwürdig. Das war für mich wirklich merkwürdig. Und das ist immer dann vor ganzem Publikum, bezahlen Leute dann Geld dafür, sich das anzugucken? Bewusstseinslage oder Bewusstseinslage. It's a noun, it's from an originally German word. A Bewusstseinslage is a state of consciousness or a feeling devoid of sensory components,
as in Dr. Dieter described his son's attitude toward academic matters as an apathetic Bewusstseinslage.
Can you please repeat both pronunciations?
There are very slight variants, so Bewusstseinslage and Bewusstse ,,Bewusstseinslager", und ,,Bewusstseinslager". ,,Bewusstseinslager". German, sehr klar zu ihrer phonetischen Struktur, aber das ist ein langes Wort mit vielen Syllablen und vielen ... Ist das Kommentator? Ja, ja, das glaube ich nicht, ist so geil. Und sie schreibt jetzt das Wort so in der Luft, auf einer Tastatur. So hilft sie sich anscheinend. B E W U S S Aber wie unfair, einfach Wörter aus einer komplett anderen Sprache. Ich meine, woher soll man das denn wissen? Mein Tipp ist, sie schreibt einem Doppel-S vor dem T. Bewusstsein. Bewusstseinswahl. Aber er wird schon genervt, ne? Sie hat nur noch 28 Sekunden.
Ah, okay. Das ist ja spanninslager. I fucking called it. Bewusstseinslager ist welt B-E-W-U-S-S-T-S-E-I-N-S-L-A-G-E. Thank you. Ah, nein! Ach nein. Aber hey, I called it. Ja, gut gemacht. Das ist vielleicht das Einzige, was wir können. Wir können die Wörter nicht buchstabieren. Wir können gut erraten, wer woran genau scheitert. Wer an den deutschen Wörtern, woran scheitert. Aber richtig, also, herzlichen Glückwunsch an den tatsächlichen Gewinner, Kartik Nemani. Muss der dann das gleiche Wort machen? Nein. Aber das ist dann bescheuert. Ja, aber dann weisst du es ja schon, wie es ... Okay, Kartik Nemani, dein Wort ist Tree. Aber du meinst, dass er es nicht hört, was sie sagt und er dann es nochmal ... Ja, wie bei Schalke den Ra. Richtig unsympathisch, weil er war dann auch eingeblendet, als sie es falsch gemacht hat. Er freut sich. Und er hat demonstrativ den Kopf geschüttelt, als sie einen Fehler gemacht hat.
Mein Gott, dein einzige Konkurrentin verliert gerade schon. Musst du jetzt sagen, kannst du nicht sagen, ja, ist ein schweres Wort. Ja, ist ein wirklich schweres Wort. Sorry, weiß ich nicht, ob ich es auch geschafft hätte. Nee, und der, nein, falsch. Nein, mit zwei S. Nee, ich bin da wirklich auf ihrer Seite. Also, vielleicht nächstes Jahr kriegst du es hin. Aber was war dann sein Wort? Ist es ja unmöglich, als Jury vorher ein Wort mit exakt der gleichen Schwierigkeit zu bestimmen. Ja, guter Punkt. Und es ist doch gar kein Problem, ihm Kopfhörer aufzusetzen für die Zeit. Ja, vor allem, warum kriegt er denn nicht auch dann ein deutsches Wort, oder? Also dann irgendwie, naja, ich weiß nicht, ob das dann leichter ist, wenn man dann schon so drin ist, aber er hat dann so ein griechisches Wort bekommen, was dann halt einfach, also ich weiss nicht, du kannst ja mal gucken, ob du es hättest buchstabieren können. Okay. Koinonia. Koinonia may have the definition. Intimate spiritual communion and participative sharing in a common religious commitment and spiritual community. May have the language of origin. Er ist so nervig. Griech. Are there any alternative Pronunziations? There's koinonia and kinonia. So, Stefan, koinonia. Koinonia. Koinonia. Koinonia. Koinonia. Können Sie das im Satz benutzen? Warte, er hat einen tollen Satz. There's koinonia and kinonia. May I have the part of speech? Noun. Can you please repeat the word? Koinonia, kinonia. Koinonia, k. K. Ja, ich hätte schon C gesagt. Okay, gib mir koinonia. Nee, ist der Griechische, ist in K. Koinonia, Koinonia, K-O-I-N-A-N-I-A. Leider falsch. Bling! O statt A, K-O-I-N-O-N-I-O-N-ja. Koinonia. Schwierig, aber du hättest es leider nicht geschafft. Du bist raus gewesen. Aber wäre spannender gewesen mit dir. Aber ich bin, ja, wäre spannender gewesen, wie ich dann gegen diese Elfjährige, mit so einem Riesentyp, der auf der Bühne steht. Aber Bewusstseinslage hättest du hinbekommen. Bewusstseinslage. Bewusstseinslage hättest du geschafft. Ja, schwierig. Finde ich wirklich schwierig, weil das ist deutlich einfacher. Das ist eine 50-50 Chance. Bewusstseinslage, es gibt so viele Stolpersteine. Plus er spricht es auch immer falsch aus. Lager. So, Jesus, nein, es ist ja einfach auch nicht deine Sprache. Wohingegen Kornonier, wahrscheinlich sagen die das manchmal. Aber wie gemein, war das immer so, dass dann irgendwann die Sprache wechselt einfach? Ich glaube, es muss sein.
Ich glaube, irgendwann hat man dann die englische Sprache einfach so gut verstanden, dass man jedes Wort, selbst dass man es nicht kennt, anhand des Klangs oder so dann irgendwie rekonstruieren kann.
Es ist halt, ich glaube auch, da wird es immer schwerer.
Und ich meine, was ist das Limit?
Was ist das absolute Limit?
Ich meine, das waren jetzt die Elfjährigen von heute. Was sind die Elfjährigen in 30 Jahren in der Lage zuität. Eure zehn Minuten laufen ab jetzt. Das will ich sehen. Er schneidet das Ei. Und der Kommentator so, ich sehe es nicht genau. Er schneidet mit den Post-its das Ei. Kannst du dich vielleicht ein bisschen nach hinten nehmen? Wir haben leider nur eine Kameraeinstellung. Auch im Jahr 2300 haben wir nur eine sehr schlechte Kamera. 63 Pixel mehr haben wir nicht. Aber ganz kurze Frage an dich, wenn da jetzt wirklich ein schwarzes Loch entstehen würde, würden wir da nicht alle reingesaugt werden? Wie ist das physikalisch? Ich bin mir sicher, dass er das hinkriegt. Ich bin mir sicher, er wird auch die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen im Kopf behalten und P19 wird hier, übrigens ein sehr schöner Name, nach einer Stadt benannt, die ich sehr mag, aber die Autokonikatur macht immer P18 auch. Nach einer Kolonie auf Saturn benannt. Ja, stimmt. Nervig. Ja, und ich bin mir sicher, dass P19 auch. Oh, jetzt schauen wir mal ganz kurz, er hat das Ei ausgehöhlt, er hat das Eigelb geschlagen, stilbt es über die Grafitspitze des Bleistifts und jetzt reibt er einmal dran und tatsächlich, es scheint sich da etwas zu tun, da scheint ein Funke überzuspringen und AAAAAAAA! Und so endete leider das gesamte Universum an diesem Tag. Und er hat leider verloren. Er hat verloren gegen Wurmbloch, gegen Linda, Linda, Gruber, Linda, Linda. Nee, das finde ich ja alles nicht so schlecht. Ich finde auch dieses Competitiveness finde ich eigentlich ziemlich spannend. Das gab es bei uns nicht so. Auch diese Kängurutest nicht? Schön Mathe-T Mathe-Test? Ah ja, doch. Kängurutest. Schönen Kängurutest. Ich bin natürlich immer derjenige, der keinen Plan von Mathe hat. Aber es hieß, entweder du gehst eine Stunde zur Schule oder du machst den Kängurutest. Und ich aus der letzten Reihe ... Oh nein. Und die ganzen Mitglieder deines Teams, die Mathleads. Ich würde gerne teilnehmen. Ich würde gerne teilnehmen. Sie sagten eine Stunde frei, dann in der ...
Ja, frei nicht, du bist ja beim Kängurutest.
Genau, aber angenommen, ich fülle den jetzt mal so Larifari aus und gebe ihn ab.
Buchstablier Larifari.
L-F-F.
Ja.
Ah.
Nein, du darfst nicht zum Kängurutest.
Ich war im Kängurutest richtig schlecht abgeschnitten, weil die Fragen auch link waren irgendwie und die Tinte war ich gleich, ich konnte es kaum lesen. Aber, ähm, ja, naja. Naja, ich war da auch mal bei, das weiß ich schon auch, aber sonst gab's nicht so richtig sowas. Gut, ich war bei so einem Schülerunternehmen, da gab's Wettbewerbe, aber ich hab jetzt nicht so Mathe- oder Wissenswettbewerbe gehabt.
Auch so diese Special, wo auch Supertalent und so herkommt, America's Got Talent-to-Talent-Wettbewerbe.
Ja, diese Talent-Shows, das gibt's in Deutschland auch nicht so viel.
Oder auch mal so Schülerbands, die so nachher da auftreten.
Germany doesn't have talent, doesn't got talent.
Doesn't got talent, no, doesn't got grammar.
Ain't no gotten talent, ain't no talent. Doesn't got talent. No, got, doesn't got grammar. Ain't no gotten talent. Ain't no talent in Germany. Ain't no talent in Germany. The merkwürdige Show. There ain't. There ain't any talent in Germany. Bei Deutschland tritt an, um zu beweisen, dass sie in der ganzen Welt am wenigsten Talent haben. Deswegen schicken sie immer ihren schlechtesten Repräsentanten los, der schlechter sein muss als alle anderen. Die haben ein ganz eigenes Wettrennen, die wollen immer letzter Platz werden. Beim ESC klappt es ja. So, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Seitenhieb. Der holt mich ab, der holt mich ab, der wird mich abgeholt, der wird mich gehört. Ja. Meine Frage wäre, weil in allen Ländern suchen die ja für den ESC immer in coolen Wettbewerben die Talents. In There Ain't No Talent in Germany, Good Old Germany, darf immer der NDR irgendwen bestimmen. Der NDR in so einem Altbacken-Team zeigt auf Leute, die das dann machen müssen. Ich frage mich, warum kann man das nicht genauso machen? Cooles Auswahlverfahren, viele Musikerinnen. Du meinst so Ninja Warrior für Musiker, oder was? Ja, oder einfach Ninja Warrior und der Gewinner kriegt dann einen Song geschrieben, auf den Leib geschnitten. Ja, das ist eine grosse rotierende Platte und der, der als letztes stehen bleibt, gewinnt. Einfach so, wir haben keine andere Möglichkeit. Es geht ja eh nur mit dem Song. Wir sind am Ende unserer Optionen, Deutschland, immer Nullpunkte. Wir machen jetzt einfach eine große Schaukel und die wird immer schneller. Und welcher Sänger als letztes noch draufgehebt wird. Oder so Takeshys Castle mässig. Aber dann alles so Instrumententhematisch. Also da werden dann so Saxophone geworfen oder so. Und wer am Ende dann irgendwie in die Posaune tröten kann, der hat dann gewonnen. Und so eine Riesenoboe dreht sich. Man muss immer über die Oboe springen. Und wenn man zu spät springt, dann ballert die Oboe einen weg. Oder so eine riesige Gitarre, wo du auf den sechs Saiten so balancieren musst, so sechs Musiker fangen an, und dann musst du dann noch so Töne machen, auf so einem riesigen Klavier wie ein Big. Ja, genau. So, und der Gewinner, die Gewinnerin, ist nicht zwangsweise eher ein guter Athlet, als gut Musikerin oder Musiker. Und den schreiben wir dann einen mega, mega Song auf den Live. Auf diesem großen, riesigen Klavier. Genau, alles mit riesigen Instrumenten. Alle anderen Musiker müssen sich aufstellen, weil wir brauchen ja viele Leute, um das zu spielen. Und die müssen dann unter genervten Blicken, ich hab's nicht geschafft, müssen trotzdem das Lied mitkomponieren. Ja, genau. Und haben dann so halbgare Vorschläge wie vielleicht A-Moll, weiß ich nicht.
Wieso?
Weiß ich keiner. Aber ich habe Grundlage, sagst du jetzt A-Moll.
Um hier auch mal was zu sagen.
Dennis.
Ja, sorry.
Dennis auf der Grundlage kommt super,
eine genervte Stimmung auch direkt.
Ja, irgendwo muss man anfangen, irgendwo muss man anfangen.
Schon gut, dass ein Klavier genau so groß ist,
dass die Finger draufdrücken können. Zum Glück ist es nicht, stell dir vor, man bräuchte die ganze Hand um eine Taste Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehränden so eine Taste nach der anderen drücken musst, mit der ganzen Kraft. Zum Glück passt das genau so zusammen. Ja, und zum Glück kann man sowohl an die höchste Taste kommen, als auch mit dem Stuhl, ohne einen Drehstuhl zu haben. Ja, so einen Rutschuhl auf so Schienen. Du brauchst den Stuhl auf Schienen und musst dich immer so hin und her schienen. Die ersten Klavierer hatten Schienensysteme davor und mit Kohle wurde dann so eine kleine Lok betrieben, um dich nach links und rechts zu bringen. Ein Riesenaufwand, Konzertsaal voller Rauch, viel Rauch, viel Rauch, und man hat primär das gehört, dieses Schienensystem. War nervig. Es war nervig. Nee, es ist auch gut, ne, denke ich mir. Ja, das ist richtig gut. Das ist ein Tennisball, genau diese Dichtigkeit und dieses Gewicht, dass man den relativ gut rüberbekommt. Und dass die Gitarre auch kurz genug ist, dass du mit der rechten Hand zupfen und mit der linken Hand greifen kannst. Früher kann es ja gut sein, dass die so lang waren, dass du zwei Leute gebraucht hast. Der eine, der links war und die Seiten gedrückt hat, und der andere, der sich angeschlagen hat. Und du konntest nur wie so ein Tandem. Voll gut. Und der eine sagt, darf ich mal anschlagen? Nee. Nee. Auch gut, dass Autos genau so gross sind, dass meistens vier bis fünf Leute reinpassen, weil mehr braucht man nicht. Mehr braucht man meist nicht. Genau, es passt eigentlich die richtige Größe. Man kann alleine fahren und man kann auch seine Kumpel mitbringen. Genau, man kann auch alleine fahren und dann noch Sachen transportieren. Früher waren Autos ja so klein, dass nicht mal eine Person reingepasst hat. Nein. Und du konntest dann irgendwie das Auto dann so einmal Gas geben, du drückst einmal aufs Gas und dannährst weg und dann musst du hinterherlaufen dem Auto. Ja, und dann bleibt es irgendwo stehen, wo man vielleicht gar nicht, gar nie hinwollt. Ja, genau, weil du kannst dir nur einmal lenken und dann draufdrücken und du musst dann immer hinterherlaufen. Also das ist, da sind wir mittlerweile echt schon weiter. Das finde ich auch gut, dass wir Fortschritte gemacht haben. Auch gut, dass Trinkflaschen genau so gross sind, dass man meistens danach auch genug hat, wenn die dann leer ist. Ja, genau. Also, dass da wirklich eine gute Menge drin ist, du bist dann gesättigt, aber du bist dann auch gut dabei. Wie die Welt funktioniert. Ja, dass das alles so perfekt passt. Jetzt kommt ein Curveball, den ich dazu werfe. Aber auch gut, dass Pferde genau so gross sind, dass man sich gut draufsetzen kann und die einen wegbringen. Weil das ist jetzt naturgemacht. Stark, stark. Gut, dass Bananen auch die perfekte Grösse haben. Naja, wobei, da würde ich jetzt auch ein großes Fragezeichen dran machen. Nee, aber Kürbisse zum Beispiel, die haben die perfekte Grösse, um ausgehöhlt und mit einer Lampe drinnen zu werden. Um Gesicht zu bekommen. Die sind nicht zu klein, die sind nicht zu gross. Ich meine, in Apfel oder so kriegst du kein Gesicht rein, Kürbis ist gross genug. Aber jetzt gibt es kaum ein Gemüse, was es in mehr Grössen gibt als in, Kürbis gibt es in XXXL bis XS. Ja, Kürbis recht variabel, wohl gegen Kirschen? Immer klein. Gib mir mal eine Kirsche, die so gross ist wie eine Orange oder wie eine Melone, gib mir mal so eine richtig grosse Kirsche. Da hätte ich ja so mal Bock drauf. Warum sind die so klein? Da hätte ich ja so Bock drauf. Ich hoffe, es ist eine riesen Kirsche in der Hand. Warum kann man die nicht gross zichten? So eine apfelgrosse Kirsche, mir läuft das Wasser im Mund zusammen. Leute, apfelgrosse Kirsche. Ja, arbeite da mal dran. Und kirschgrosse Äpfel. Ja. So snacken. Wohingegen Bananen? Gerne kleiner. Gerne kleiner, so wie bei Truppi Frutti. Gerne so kleine snackbare Bananen. Aber muss man trotzdem aufmachen wie so ein Babybel? Dann ist nämlich die Babybel RatioRatio funktioniert nämlich nicht. Babybell ist viel zu viel zu knibbeln, für wenig Ertrag. Brauch Babybell wirklich eigentlich noch diese Plastikverpackung? Weil du hast ja diese Wachshülle. Brauchen die wirklich noch die Plastik? Das stimmt. Doppelt eingepackt muss das denn wirklich sein. Wirklich, die sind in einem Netz. Wenig in der Welt ist so gut beschützt wie Babybelts eigentlich, oder?
Naja, Babys generell.
Drei Verteidigungslinien gegen den Eindringling.
Netz.
Und du denkst, das ist ein einfach drin.
Plastik, Wachs.
Auch unterschiedlichster Art.
Es kann sein, dass ein Angreifer durch das Netz kommt,
aber dann nicht durch die Plastikfolie.
Nee, genau.
Ein anderer käme vielleicht durch die Plastikfolie,
aber gar nicht erst durchs Netz.
Nee, genau. So, deswegen ist es eigentlich ideal. Wachs für niemanden ein Problem. Nee, Wachs ist kein Problem. Und ich sag mal so, es kam auch schon vor, dass ich das Wachs mitgegessen habe. Sorry? Wirklich jetzt? Das Geständnis? Nein. Ich sitze hinter der ... Zum Glück sitze ich hinter der Schattenwand. Zum Glück haben wir die aufgebaut für die heutige Folge. Dann kann ich das auch gerne mal ... Wir machen heute die große Geständnis-Folge. Hast du mal ein Labello gegessen? Nee, Labello hatte ich nie. Ich hab mal ein Labello reingebissen. Aber so einen vorsichtigen kleinen Minibiss oder wirklich so einen saftigen, wie du jetzt in Snickers reinbeissen würdest? So richtig all in. Nee, Snickers nicht, aber schon ein bisschen all in. Aber du hast nicht erst mal daran geleckt, sondern direkt reingebissen. Ich hab davor oft dran ... also ist ja dran lecken quasi, die Lippen zu benetzen. Und dann mit der Zunge drüber die benetzten Lippen zu fahren. Ist ja im Prinzip lecken. Und dann weiss man ja schon, you know what you get. Und dann kann man auch mal ein bisschen aus dem Labello nehmen. Nee, ich dachte einfach lange, also ich dachte ein Babybel lange, dass man das Wachs mit isst. Bevor wir meine Eltern wieder so auf die Nase gehauen haben, so Spucks aus, Spucks aus, Spucks aus. Die wussten schon, was sie tun müssen. Wie bei Hunden, die man so in den Mundwinkeln juckt, damit die sich übergeben. Ja genau, so an den Halsrand, Spucks aus, Spucks aus, weil ich ständig alles irgendwie essen wollte. Aber lass uns heute mal wirklich alles gestehen, das alles gestehen, einfach mal alles raus. Mal wirklich einfach mal so mit einem weissen Blatt neu anfangen. Ich glaub, ich hab inzwischen auch alle schon mal hier gestanden. Deine schlimmsten Taten hast du hier schon mal gestanden. Ich bin so ein unbeschriebenes Blatt, was schlimme Taten angeht. Schlimme Sachen ... Was heißt schlimme Sachen, aber wo man sich denkt, boah, da bin ich nicht stolz drauf. Da bin ich nicht stolz drauf. Ich wurde mal lange gecatfischt, das kann man mal erzählen. Ja? Ja. Nicht lange, aber so bestimmt auch einen Monat oder sowas, ja. Also was bedeutet das genau? Ich habe mit einer Person geschrieben, von der ich dachte, sie wäre eine Person in meinem Alter. Und es kam dann irgendwann raus, weil Messenger gewechselt wurden, dass es gar nicht sich immer eine Person in meinem Alter handelt, sondern um einen ekligen alten Mann. Und das ist unglaublich verstörend. Und seitdem habe ich grosse Angst vor Catfishing. Und ich finde es nicht schlimmer als Catfishing. Aber waren es durchaus romantische, flirthafte Gespräche? Ja. Es wurde auch leicht sexuell. Du hast nicht gemerkt, dass du es mit einem 50-jährigen Mann zu tun hast? Ich weiß nicht, ob es 50 war, aber älterer Mann. Aber wie hast du das dann angesprochen? Nee, nee, ich habe es sofort blockiert. Du hast nicht flirrt anges mal so ... Hättest du da nicht noch mehr rausholen können? Ich glaub nicht, dass du gerade die Tragweite verstehst, in der das emotional verstörend ist. Ich wusste nicht, wie weit das geht, aber es scheint ja dann schon mehr Interesse da gewesen zu sein. Man hat da nicht das Gefühl, da jetzt kurz den Stimmt was rauszuholen, einen Gag rauszuholen, sondern man denkt in dem Moment so, Jesus, what the hell, einem dreht sich der ganze Magen um. Und rückblickend auch alle anderen Gespräche, Moment mal, mit wem war ich da zusammen eigentlich zwei Jahre? So schlimm, es war ja wie gesagt keine zwei Jahre, aber es war schon wirklich verstanden. Was ist da die Intention dahinter? Also ist es dann irgendwie ein Betrug oder ist es einfach nur Trollerei? Nee, nee. Aber meinst du, die Person kannte dich auch so von Öffentlichkeit und deswegen gerade dich oder einfach random? Nein, random, nee, nee. Es geht darum ... Es war ja auch mehr als bloss nettes Schreiben so. Es wurden sich auch Bilder geschickt. Es ist auch schon länger her, da war ich so, weiß ich nicht, siebzehn oder so sechzehn. Ach so, okay. Und ich glaube, es ging da wirklich um ... Ach, okay, fuck, okay, das wusste ich nicht. Aber es wurden keine Dickpics verschickt. Ich habe keine Dickpics verschickt. Aber es wurde, genau. Aber es ist, ja. Ach du Scheiße. Ja. Und das war, da war ich, keine Ahnung, sie keine Ahnung, 17, 18 oder so. Das war ganz, ganz schlimm. Die grosse Geständnisfolge. Wer hätte das gedacht, dass es in diese Richtung geht? Aber es ist wahnsinnig. Also da muss man den grossen Appell ganz doll aufpassen. Ich meine, die meisten Hörerinnen, Hörer sind jetzt nicht mehr in dem Alter, wo sie da, glaube ich, wahnsinnig die Zielgruppe sind, aber ich glaube, gerade bei Frauen ist es noch ein großes Problem. Ich glaube, eher jüngere Männer werden gecatfischt. Jesus. Bin mir nicht sicher. Nee, ich habe da ja auch immer sehr grosse Skepsis, egal was. Gerade wenn so ein Instagram-Account ohne Profilfoto, ohne irgendwas schreibt. Ja, ja. Dann so. Und immer, immer Safety, also Personality-Checks machen. Sagt der Person, schick mal ein Bild, wo du auf den Zettel was schreibst oder sowas, oder zeig mir eine gewisse Handgeste. Und das kannst du locker ins Flirten mit einbauen, dass du sagst, schick mal ein Bild von der heutigen Zeitung mit einem Gesicht von dir. Weißt du, was mein Kink ist? Weißt du, was mein Kink ist, Isabel? Schick mir mal ein Bild von dir, wie du das Hang-Lose-Zeichen machst. Aber, und jetzt kommt's, das ist mein Kink, ich weiß, ich bin ein bisschen crazy, Hang-Lose-Zeichen, aber dann den Zeigefinger auch noch mit ausstreckst. Ah, okay, Triple-Lose. Triple-Lose, und dann schreibst du auf deinen und ich weiß, ist mega speziell und so, aber es fände ich echt mega. Nee, ich mach alles für dich. Wenn du dann auf deinem Fingernagel deines Zeigefingers ein Ich-bin's-wirklich-Isabelle drauf lackieren könntest. Okay, muss ich was anhaben, oder? Nee, ist mir egal. Mega, einfach die Hand, okay, danke. Weil das ist wichtig, es ist nicht viel Arbeit und ihr könnt so verhindern, dass sich das passiert. Auf jeden Fall, finde ich gut. Findest du, dass das Leute auch proaktiv machen sollten? Also wenn ich jetzt jemanden anschreibe im Internet, sollte ich dann proaktiv auch sagen, hier, das ist übrigens der Beweis, dass ich echt bin, oder fändest du das dann wieder zu skeptisch? Wärst du dann skeptisch, warum will die Person jetzt unbedingt das beweisen? Fändest du das sogar zuvorkommend? Zuvorkommend, ich find's super. Sollte das nicht ein normaler Teil der Internet-Flirt-Dating-Etikette sein, dass man sich sofort vertrauend aufbauend Beweise schickt, dass man ein echter Mensch ist? Genau, Tinder hat das jetzt inzwischen auch. Man kann dann Selfie-Check, man gibt es auch den blauen Haken, dann bist du nicht eine berühmte Person auf Tinder, sondern du bist, wenn du den blauen Haken mit Tinder hast, hast du dich verifiziert. Du hast denen ein Live-Foto geschickt von dir und so. Dann guckt ein Team, das ist der Mensch auf den Fotos. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt. Und die sagen dann, mach mal das Hang-Lose-Zeichen. Das Hang-Lose-Zeichen, aber mit einem Mittelfinger aus. Ja, das ist, also Internet ist gefährlich, ist ein gefährliches Flaster. Ja, ja. Es sieht nie so aus, weil alles immer bunt und hell und schön ist. Und die Userfotos auch immer sehr freundlich sind. Immer sehr freundlich und toll und hot. Aber es ist ein gefährliches Pflaster. Ja, krass. Ich überleg gerade, wie oft mir das vielleicht auch passiert ist, ohne dass ich es gemerkt habe. Aber in dem Alter so, da habe ich nichts gemacht. Da habe ich Warhammer-Figuren im Keller gemalt. Da ist man relativ sicher vor solchen Cyberangreifen. Ja, bemalt Warhammer-Figuren im Keller. Wirklich, ohne Scheiß, dann passiert euch so ein Quatsch. Passiert euch nicht, heutzutage ist es ja auch total leicht. Dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, wie schlimm das jetzt war. Also man hat sich das ... Ich war erst sehr traumatisiert, aber auch niemand hat darüber gesprochen. Aber irgendwann dachte ich mir, ist ja auch ein bisschen egal, weil ich hätte mich eh nie mit der Person getroffen.
Nee, nein, er hat so weit weg gelebt, also weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber und man wusste auch nicht viel übereinander, also es ist nicht so, dass irgendwie dieser alte Mann mir dann auflauern könnte oder sowas.
Und im Prinzip hatte man einfach nur eine gute Zeit, haltalt nicht mit ... und da man sich auch nie getroffen hat, ist es ja auch ein bisschen egal. Also ich habe ja, wenn ich mich gefreut habe über Nachrichten, mich über die Idee der Nachricht, der Person gefreut. Wie egal ist es denn dann eigentlich? Es war wie ein Lab, wie ein Rollenspiel. Bei dem du halt nur einer wusste, dass es ein Lab ist. Ja, mit dem großen Unterschied. Dass ich dachte, ich bin ein fucking Mittelalter. Hm. Ja, okay. Ja, sorry, wenn du jetzt fragst. Nee, finde ich nicht, finde ich gut. So eine offene Gesprächskultur. Ich mag auch die Moral. Und dann sagt jemand was und dann ist grosses Scheiße.
Nein, ich mag auch die Moral der Geschichte.
Seid da auf jeden Fall vorsichtig.
Ich überlege nur rückblickend, wie oft mir das hätte passieren können,
ohne dass ich es merke.
Ist wahrscheinlich auch viel passiert, aber dann auch noch mal jetzt.
Aber was ist dann der Grund?
Weil ich dachte so, dass man dann irgendwo so ein Treffen organisiert
und dann irgendwie da weiterkommt.
Das wollen ja Catfisher nie. Catfisher wollen Leute verarschen. Die wollen einfach nur Leute verarschen. Ja, genau. Also, ja, ich glaube, es ist einfach so eine Mischung aus Fotos haben wollen und der Reiz. Ja, ja, okay. Catfishing is a problem. Lass uns das nicht verschweigen. Nee, auf keinen Fall. Und haut einfach alles mal in die Google-Bildersuche, ne? Schadet nicht. Ja, Reverse-Image.
Einfach Reverse-Image-Suche von allen Bildern, die ihr kriegt, und dann guckt mal, ob da irgendwie so catfish.de oder so die anbieten oder so, dann habt ihr vielleicht einen kleinen Hinweis. Ist eh gut, Bild hochladen und gucken, ob es das schon mal irgendwo gibt, ist eine clevere Sache. Ja. Ähm, ja, das ist auch wichtig. Ja, seid da vorsichtig, seid da vorsichtig. Das ist wirklich ...
Warum heißt es Catfish, sind es diese ... Da brauche ich dich. Ja, seid da vorsichtig, seid da vorsichtig.
Heute ist die Geständnisfolge. Aber Catfish, sind es diese Anglerfische oder was? Und die locken dich an mit ihrer Lampe und dann fressen sie dich auf oder was? Deswegen heißt es, aber Katzenfisch ist... Also, Catfishing ist Enttäuschungsaktivität, bei der eine Person im sozialen Netzwerk eine gefälschte Online-Identität, jetzt in Klammern Sockenpuppe, erstellt und sich in der Regel zielgerichtet ein bestimmtes Opfer auszut. Das ist der Fachbegriff, das für Sockenpuppe ist der Fake-Account. Sockenpuppe, als Sockenpuppe, eigentlich Sock-Puppet, auch Fake-Account, bezeichnet man im Netz-Gargon ein zusätzliches Benutzerkonto, das aus verschiedenen Gründen angelegt wurde. Finstagram, kenn ich. Ähm, dass man einen Instagram-Account hat und einen Finstagram hat. Sockenpuppe klingt auch schon finlos. Aber warum heißt es Catfishing? Was ist ein Catfish? Der Begriff Catfishing hat seine Wurzeln in einer amerikanischen Anekdote. Freut euch schon. Secondhand-Anekdote, viel Spaß. Die auf einem Mythos beruht, laut dem Katzenwälse, englisch Catfish, eingesetzt wurden, um lebende Dorsche während des Transports in Bewegung zu halten und sie vor Lethargie zu bewahren. Als Begriff für Liebesbeziehungen mit Fake-Accounts wird er erstmals im Dokumentarfilm Catfish des Filmemachers Neff Schulman aus dem Jahr 2010 und der darauf aufbauenden Reality-Show Catfish verwendet. Als Abwandlung von Catfishing wird scherzhafter Begriff Hatfishing von Hat-Hut für Männer verwendet, die auf derjenigen Portale ihren Haarausfall bewerben. Also wenn ihr Glatzer bekommt, sie immer Hut aufsetzenzen, dann macht ihr Headfishing. Moment mal, diese Katzenwälse waren im selben Becken wie Dorsche und die Dorsche hatten Angst vor denen und sind deswegen immer in Bewegung geblieben, damit die nicht lethargisch, damit die nicht einschlafen und schlecht werden und schlecht werden in der Dorschlieferung. Ich glaube, die gehen, um die sich von Lethargie zu bewahren. Ich weiß aber nicht, wer dann Wingen jagt. Aber warum ist denn Lethargie ein Problem? Ich lebe seit acht Jahren in Lethargie und mir geht es super. Ich finde vor allem diese Metapher jetzt wahnsinnig schwierig, weil dieser alte Mann hat mich jetzt nicht vor Lethargie befahrt, ehrlich gesagt. Und es geht auch darum, dass der dich immer in Bewegung hält, oder wie, dass er die immer wieder schreibt. Das liest nicht so gut. Was für eine merkwürdige Metapher. Und supergruselig ist aber rechtliche Bewertung. Okay. Die Frage nach der Strafbarkeit von Fake-Profilen und Catfishing kann nicht fallübergreifend beantwortet werden. Es kommt immer auf die individuelle Fallbewertung an. Und bei mir, glaube ich, lag auch einfach kein Strafbestand vor. Warum? Ich habe den Moment, wo dann Fotos ausgetauscht werden und der Content fehlt, weil es nicht die Person ist, von der ich glaube, dass es ist, dann liegt bestimmt ein Strafbestand vor. Aber keine Ahnung. Super schwierig, super grauzonig und einfach vorsichtig sein. Apropos Sockenpuppe, ähm ... Es gab einen lustigen Artikel über uns, wir mussten eine Show absagen.
Oh ja.
Wegen eines Covid-Falls.
Von einem von uns beiden. Von einem von uns beiden, was nicht nachhaltig geklärt werden kann. Und in diesem Artikel stand, dass das Komiker-Duo Stefan Thietze und Florentin nicht auftreten können. Wir können es mal vorlesen. Wegen Corona-Erkrankung. Podcast-UFO erst am 17. Juli. Die Pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei. Aufgrund einer Corona-Erkrankung im Ensemble muss die für Dienstag, 5. Juli geplante Vorstellung von Das Podcast-Ufo verlegt werden. Ab 20 Uhr wollte das schillernde Humorgespann aus Stefan Tietze und Florentin im Theater am Egi auftreten. Und das ist fantastisch. Stefan Tietze und Florentin. Nee, ich finde auch, das einfach unironisch übernommene, schillernde Humorgespann aus Stefan Tietze und Florentin klingt einfach, als hätte ich eine Handpuppe. Als würde Stefan Tietze mit seiner Handpuppe auftreten. Stefan Tietze mit Florentin. Ja, mit dem Florentin. Mit Florentin. Florentin raucht und ist immer genervt und will eigentlich gar nicht dabei sein. Ja, ganz merkwürdig, aber auch sehr gut fand ich, seit 2014 hat das Duo mehr als 250 Episoden aufgenommen. Wir haben 318 Folgen rausgebracht. Warum man das als mehr als 250 beschreibt, ist mir auch nicht klar. Na ja, ein Vierteljahr, Viertelhundert, Vierteltausend. Ich meine, es stimmt schon, aber warum nicht mehr als 300? Ich meine, das ist so eine passiv-aggressive Art, um zu sagen, der arbeitet seit 20 Jahren in der Firma. Mensch, du bist ja jetzt auch schon mehr als sieben Jahre dabei, ne? Ja, 20. Wie, Gitarrist XY zählt zu den besten, ist unter die besten zwölf Gitarristen der Welt gekommen. Wo man auch weiß, ja, Platz zwölf.
Das will man ja elf sagen.
Ja, oder er ist Platz drei und er sagt, warum schreibt er denn unter die besten zwölf? Platz zwölf.
Ich bin Platz drei.
Ja, genau.
Schreib doch die besten drei.
Ja, aber du bist doch unter den besten zwölf.
Naja, aber alte Journalismusregel, du sagst entweder 250, 500, 750 oder 1000.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so eine gute Regel.
300 ist nicht möglich.
Du hast Journalismus studiert, nicht ich.
Etwas über 300. Ja, oder etwas weniger als 500, hätte man ja auch sagen können. Aber das war jetzt von zu viel. Knapp 500. Mehr als 250. Da kann man ja, Journalismus ist ja auch formbar, das ist sehr lehm. Kannst ja auch ein bisschen drücken. Wahnsinn. Ja, verrückt, aber tut es leid für alle, die leider nicht kommen konnten, aber wir hatten einen tollen Auftritt in Hannover, der hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht und den habt ihr ja letzte Woche schon gehört.
Genau. Das war lustig. Da haben wir jetzt auch nichts mehr dazu zu sagen. Genau.
Nee, ich wüsste auch nicht, was ich darüber sagen soll.
Es gibt nichts hinzuzufügen oder zu klarifizieren. Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt gibt es darüber nicht viel zu sagen. Vielleicht irgendwann anders, aber momentan nicht. Momentan haben wir dazu nichts zu sagen. Momentan wüssten wir beide nicht, was wir dazu sagen sollen. Wir könnten sehr allgemeine Dinge sagen, aber wenn es darüber hinausgeht, spezifischer wird, dann könnten wir dann nichts mehr sagen. Jetzt gerade. Heute. So, Anwälte können den Raum verlassen, wir haben das Thema. Wir kriegen Flams ab von allen vier Anwälten und dann macht's gut, ne? Jo. Dass da nicht zurückkam, übrigens wir hatten viele quatschige Ideen in dem Podcast, viele dumme Ideen, dass Anwälte, der billige Anwalt.org nicht zu einem Thing wurde, habe ich nicht verstanden. Ja, dass man zwei billige Anwälte zum Preis von einem Guten kriegt, damit man sagen kann, sie hören von meinen Anwälten. Ja, oder. Damit man einfach rechtlich abgesichert Plural benutzt. Jeder hat einen Anwalt, eine Anwältin, so und wir machen einfach das Plural dazu. Genau. Plural. Ja, wenden Sie sich da einfach an meine Anwälte. Und da hast du einfach zwei Anwälte. Damit man das sagen kann. Ja, einer ist 14 oder so, aber rechtlich gesehen, dadurch, dass er ein Praktikum da macht, darf man sagen Anwalt oder was auch immer, da man sich dann zurecht strickt. Aber uns geht es einfach nur um den Plural. Plural.de, Plural.de. Plu.ral. Kann man da nicht noch was machen. Ja. In Raledonien oder sowas machen wir uns das schöne Domain. Ja, das verste ich, das verstehe ich nicht, warum dann ist es einfach untergegangen. Nehmen wir zu viele Folgen auf, dass Dinge, dass Goldideen untergehen? Ich habe das Gefühl, unsere Community hängt uns noch drei Folgen hinterher. Die haben noch gar nicht die App programmiert, wo man die Bananen scannen kann und die einem sagt, wann die Banane gut ist. Die hängen einfach hinterher. Die kommen zu nichts. Leute, keep up. Macht mal voran hier. Macht mal jetzt wirklich eine Crunchwoche, wo ihr einfach mal Sachen abarbeitet, zum Beispiel unsere Podcast-UFO- App-Idee oder die App, das Podcast-UFO. Ja, genau. Dann hatten wir ja, glaube ich, vor einigen Folgen noch das Podcast-UFO als App-Idee. Ja, macht das doch mal, arbeitet das doch mal ab, bitte einfach. Und zwar heisst, wir machen mal die Crunchweeks jetzt. Ja, jetzt kommen die Crunchweeks. Mal Dinge abarbeiten. Weg damit. Also, eine Hälfte muss eine Liste erarbeiten mit allen Dingen, die wir mal hier hatten. Schnell, am ersten Tag. Dann ranken wir die nach, also wir priorisieren die. Dauert nicht lange. Beste Idee oben, schlechte Idee unten und wir arbeiten trotzdem alles von oben nach unten ab. Es wird immer langweilig, die Arbeit wird immer nerviger. So, so machen wir das. Je mehr ihr vorankommt, desto langweiliger werden eure Aufgaben. Man kann auch überlegen, dass wir Incentive gute Ideen, die wir alle mögen, dazwischen bauen. Ja, so als Milestones, oh ja, als Tentpoles, das finde ich sehr gut. So genau, und die andere Hälfte müsst ihr das dann umsetzen, bitte. Und dann könnt ihr immer in dieser offenen Google-Tabelle abhaken, wenn ihr das zufriedenstellend abgearbeitet habt. So, und das nennen wir Keeping up with the Podcast UFO, nennen wir die ganzen ... Keeping up with the Lawyers. Keeping up with-UFO, dass wir die fucking Ideen mal runterarbeiten. Ja, nee, finde ich gut. Ist ja nicht alles Gold. Nee, meistens Silber. Viel Quatsch. Viel Bronze, viel Kupfer auch dabei. Viel Zink. Ganz viel Zink dabei. Quarz. Richtig, eine Handvoll Quarz. Nee. Nee. Es ist immer noch so lame, dass Meteoriten, die auf der Erde landen, aus fucking Eisen sind.
Aus Eisen.
Fucking Eisen, Uran oder so, wie wäre es denn damit mal?
Mal irgendwas Cooles oder irgendwie so ein Isotop oder irgendwas, was es bei uns noch nicht geben kann, weil es unseren Planeten noch nicht lang genug gibt oder irgendwie so ein Quatsch.
Glibber.
Ja, mal so Schleimiges.
Neon-Glibber.
Einfach mal so ein großer Rotz-Meteorit, einfach nicht immer diese Gesteine, sondern einfach mal so ein zack, so ein Ding einfach dahingelegt. Ja, ja, aber nein, Eisen. Eisen? Hier habt ihr mehr Eisen. Ja, mein Gott. Wird die Erde immer schwerer? Das ist meine Frage, die ich stellen möchte. Wird die Erde nicht immer schwerer? Gefiffen, wie so ein Kind, was im Zahnböcker. Schwerer? Schwerer? Sch, schwer, schwer, schwer, wird die Erde immer schwerer? Wird sie schwerer, schwerer, schwerer, schwerer, nee, wird sie doch. Ja, aber da haut ja auch eine Menge ab, wir hauen ja Satelliten raus. Ach ja. Ja, aber zum Beispiel diese Black-Eyed-Peace-Sonde mit der goldenen Schallplatte der Black-Eyed-Peace, die ist ja weg. Das war ja irgendwann auch mal auf der Erde und ist jetzt weg. Ozonloch, da haut auch eine Menge ab. Nee. Nee? Nee, ich meine, was uns am Boden hält. Masse ist gleich Gravitationskraft. Ich sehe es schon kommen, einfach. Stefan, du bist wirklich wie jemand auf so einer Halfpipe, der so ganz oben und du denkst dir, nee, der fährt jetzt nicht runter. Und du kippst schon und du siehst schon,
ich muss mir den Rest des Videos gar nicht angucken, ich weiß, was passiert.
Man sieht auch an meiner Körperhaltung, dass ich das noch nie
gemacht habe. Und auch,
dass du keine Schutzkleidung anhast
und irgendwie so ein Snoopy-T-Shirt anhast und einfach
gar nicht so aussiehst wie die anderen, die das
machen auf der Halfpipe, man merkt schon, das wird
nichts. Der Krankenwagen steht schon bereit.
Der steht einfach schon am Straßenland. Je größer der
Planet, desto mehr Masse, desto mehr Anziehungskraft. Und desto grösser wird er, meinst du, da war ja mehr Asteroiden, Meteoriten anzieht. Nein, nein, nein, in diese Richtung wollte ich gar nicht gehen. Und irgendwann haben wir nur noch einen riesigen Planeten, der alles aufgefressen hat. Nee, aber der fällt in sich zusammen, weil er zu schwer wird und das wird dann ein schwarzes Loch. Nee, was ich sagen wollte ist, je grösser der Planet, desto grösser die Erdanziehungskraft. Und das heißt, in dem Moment, wo wir die Black Eyed Peas ins All geschickt haben, die Band singend, ist hier ein bisschen leichter geworden. Habt ihr gemerkt, konnte man ein bisschen höher springen. Ja, dadurch hat sich auch die Umlaufbahn der Erde verändert. Bisschen. Weil wenn wir weniger Masse haben, werden wir auch wieder weniger angezogen. Aber das unmerklich. Was alle gemerkt haben, ist, dass man ein bisschen höher springen kann. Du kannst jetzt einfach das Wort unmerklich sagen. Warum ist es unmerklich? Weil man das nicht feststellen kann. Wohingegen wir alle gemerkt haben, oh, springen fällt mir heute leichter. Das war das berühmte Jahr 1983, wo man die Basketballkörbe ein bisschen höher setzen musste, weil plötzlich dann alle leichter springen.
Und die Golfbahnen alle grösser, weil die Gravitation nicht mehr so stark ist.
Stell dir vor, die Erde ist ein großer Pool und der ist voll mit Menschen. So eine L.A. Poolparty. Und dann sind die Black Eyed Peas ausgestiegen und rausgegangen und der ganze Wasserspiegel ist gesunken.
Okay. Und dann mussten alle tiefer ins Wasser?
Genau.
Und allen war kalt. Ja. Und die Musik war aus. Okay. Ja, Herr Professor, und was sollen wir jetzt dagegen machen? Also, haben Sie eine Idee oder raten Sie uns jetzt zu ... Nein, da hilft nur warten, bis die nächsten Asteroiden auf die Erde kommen. Also wir müssen gar nichts machen? Nee. Überhaupt nichts. Aber wenn dann zu viele Asteroiden auf die Erde ballern, die sind nur aus Eisen, lame, dann wird es dir zu schwierig zu springen. Dann müssen wir entweder die Basketballkörper runterhängen oder die Band U2 ins All schicken. Gut, aber das können wir dann entscheiden, wenn es soweit ist, oder? Also da müssen wir jetzt noch keine Entscheidung treffen. Das können wir dann entscheiden, wenn es so weit ist. Okay. Und könnten wir nicht so einen grossen Kescher ...
We cross that bridge when we get there.
Wir überqueren die Brücke, wenn wir da angekommen sind.
Okay, und können wir so einen grossen Kescher bauen,
mit dem wir noch mehr Asteroiden ...
Wir können auch Kescher ins All schicken.
Nein, nein, nein, ich meine, wir bauen einen grossen Space-Cescher
und fangen noch mehr Asteroiden,
die uns normalerweise gar nicht treffen würden.
Weil wir wollen schwerer werden. Wenn wir zu leicht wären. Ach so, ja. Können wir nicht so einen Berg oder so, einfach eigenen Asteroiden wegschießen oder so? Wir bauen den Kescher, wenn es so weit ist. Ich liebe das auch, dieses, ach, weißt du, da kümmern wir uns um Ruhe. Nee, da kümmern wir uns darum, wenn es so weit ist. Ja, ist ja dann kein dringendes Problem. Nicht den Karren aufs Eis spannen, sag ich immer. Ne, hol die Kuh vom Eis. Ne, bring die Kuh aufs Eis. Was macht denn die Karren, der Karren aufs Eis? Ne, eben, ich will ja, dass die Kuh erst gar nicht auf dem Eis ist. Das will niemand. Bring die Kuh nicht aufs Eis. Die Geschichte ist ja die, die Kuh geht aufs Eis, weil sie dann abkürzen kann. Weil der Bauer denkt, ne, dann müssen wir nicht den Weg um den See machen, sondern über den See. Und dann sagt der andere Bauer, ja, dann müssen wir jetzt die Kuh auf dem Eis holen. Das ist die Anekdote? Das ist die Geschichte. Das ist der Ursprung, ja. Und deswegen sage ich, nee, kürz erst gar nicht ab, sondern nimm den langen Weg. Nimm den langen, komplizierten Weg? Nimm den langen, komplizierten Weg, weil jede Abkürzung wird gefahren. Naja, lange Weg wird auch eine Menge gefahren. Was ich im Grunde sage, ist Schuhster bleib bei deinen Leisten. Das stimmt. Kuh bleib auf der Weide. Ohne genau zu wissen, was Leisten sind in dem Kontext. Aber Leisten werden irgendwas mit der Schuhproduktion zu tun haben. Also werden Schuhe aus Leisten gebaut? oder also weil Leder kommt dann oder also, Google bitte schneller. Warum der Schuster bei seinen Leisten bleiben soll und woher diese Redewendung kommt, erfahrt ihr hier. Herrlich. Als der berühmte griechische Maler Apellis eines seiner Bilder, die ich gemalt hatte, stellt er aus. Er versteckte sich in der Nähe, um unbemerkt die Meinung der Betrachter zu erfahren. Ein Schuster meinte, auf dem Bild sei ein Schuh nicht richtig gemalt. Die Kritik fand Apellis berechtigt, er korrigierte das Bild. Am nächsten Tag kam der Schuster wieder, diesmal kritisierte er die Form der Beine, die Bekleidung und noch mehr.
Das liess sich Appelles nicht gefallen, trat aus seinem Versteck hervor und rief, Schuster, bleib bei deinem Leisten, Schuster, bleib bei deinem Leisten, Schuster, bleib bei deinem Leisten, Schuster, gehen wir weiter, gehen wir weiter, okay.
Was wollte der Maler damit sagen, der Leisten ist die Modell von Schusters, die er benutzt, um Schuhe anzufertigen? Na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na naagogischer Rap. So wie ich fast alles, was ich in meiner Kindheit gelernt habe, über Strassensicherheit, wie ich im Bus war, habe ich alles durch pädagogische Raps gelernt.
Und bis heute, immer wenn jemand rappt, denke ich, oh, Vorsicht, jetzt gibt es was zu lernen.
Sagst du Halt, Stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal hinhören, was mich natürlich auf vielen Festivals einfach zu einem unerträglichen Gast macht,
weil ich sage, Moment mal, der will uns was erzählen über Bitches in House, Entschuldigung,
dass wir ein paar Sicherheitshinweise zu Bitches in House kriegen.
Was sagt Apache da über den Roller?
Oh Gott, da bin ich da raus, leider, weiß ich da nicht. Nee, ich höre ja lieber Frank Sinatra, höre ich ja lieber, weil der ist für mich Classy, den mag ich lieber als diese moderne Musik. Du findest Frank Sinatra besser als Apache? Die späten Werke, die frühen nicht, die mittleren Werke.
Was sind deine favorite Songs von Frank Sinatra, von The Frank?
And now, the end is near, so I must face my final moments. Ist alles ein Song? Unless it seems to be that in that case of which I'm certain. Er hat viele Songs, wo dann in Klammern hinten the Cha-Cha Song oder so steht. The Tequila Song. Ja, wie genauso. Mit Klammern hinten finde ich total toll Songs.
Genauso wie der Song Easy Like Sunday Morning
heisst auch easy in Klammern Like Sunday Morning.
Ah ja.
Also der heisst gar nicht Easy Like Sunday Morning, sondern easy.
Und noch übrigens?
Ja, Fuss oder?
Für alle, falls noch so eine Stimmung im Raum ist, das Ich brauche mehr. Hier ist der Song Easy. Like Sunday Morning. Ja, okay. Sagt das doch direkt. Sagt doch gleich, ist easy like Sunday Morning. Bei manchen anderen Publikum. Ich verstehe jetzt nicht, warum du dich einfach direkt sagen kannst, easy like Sunday Morning. Ja, der Song heißt eigentlich nur easy. Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht. Du hast ja noch gesagt, easy like Sunday Morning. Ja, der Song heisst eigentlich nur Easy. Ja, aber das heisst er ja nicht. Das heisst er noch gesagt, Easy Like Sunday Morning.
Nein, bei Bedarf.
Wie bei Bedarf. Wie heisst der Song jetzt?
Easy.
Like Sunday Morning als Untertier, als dazu.
Nee, aber das ...
Das ist wie Avatar, Aufbruch nach Pandora.
Ach so, was wie The Village, das Dorf.
Genau. Oder Science, Zeichen. Das ist auch, wenn man sagt, hey Leute, wollen wir uns folgenden Film anschauen, Avatar. Aufbruch nach Pandora. Naja, aber es macht erst Sinn jetzt, wo es den zweiten Teil gibt. Rückkehr nach Pandora. The End is Nigh. Wie heißt denn der neue Teil jetzt von ... Pandora schlägt zurück. Hast du den Trailer von Avatar 2 gesehen? Von Pandora schlägt zurück? Ah Rückkehr der Avatar-Ritter oder so, ich weiß auch nicht mehr genau. Das ist doch Quatsch. Lass uns bitte eine Special-Folge zu Avatar machen, so weit er raus ist. Weil ich warte auf diesen Film seit acht Jahren und ich liebe Avatar und ich habe diese riesigen Navi-Action-Figuren und es ist fantastisch. Es ist die beste Welt, die je geschaffen wurde. Besser als Tolkien. So, jetzt entspannen wir uns wieder. Ich liebe jetzt schon diese eine Überschrift, die rauskam vor zwei Tagen. Avatar 2 bekommt extreme Überlänge. Das klingt nach vier Stunden fucking 3D-Action. Extreme Überlänge, let's go. Yes, so muss es sein. Ja, die müssen ja da auch so viel noch reingeschnitten haben,
wenn der Film so lange in Produktion ist, sagt man ja, wir haben jetzt noch acht Jahre, bis er
veröffentlicht wird. Lass uns noch so einen witzigen
Dialog machen in der Cafeteria irgendwie,
wo der eine zu gross ist
und dann der gar nicht so
durch die Tür
durchkommt. Oh, Tö, jetzt habe ich
mich voll gesaugt.
Jetzt bin ich den ganzen Käffer.
Entschuldigung, nee, nee, dass der dann so in die Kantine kommt. Wer sind Sie? Ich bin Junior Writer. Ich wurde engagiert vor drei Jahren. Wisst ihr, was Junior heißt? Hält meistens die Klappe. Oh. Nee, aber schreibt es mal auf mit dem Gespräch in der Kantine. Genau, weil der so gross ist, die sind ja grösser als Menschen. Sigourney Weaver spielt wieder, ach genau, das fand ich auch so lustig, Sigourney Weaver spielt wieder mit, aber eine andere Rolle, weil Ira ist ja gestorben, sie spielt eine andere Rolle, die nichts mit Raten zu tun hatte, in der Fortsetzung des Films, in dem sie eine tragende Rolle gespielt hat. Und der neue Film heisst Avatar The Way of Water. The Way of Water. The Way of Water. Nicht zu wechseln mit The Shape of Water, ein anderer Film von Weedon. Nee, das ist ein ganz anderer Film. Ja, aber das heißt so ähnlich. Ja, aber warum kommst du jetzt damit um die Ecke? Das ist ja unnötig verwirrend für die Leute, wenn die zuhören.
Ja, eben, weil die nicht wissen, was es ist.
The Way of Water ist ein Angekündigter US-amerikanischer
Science-Fiction-Films, Regisseur James Cameron.
Aber kann man als Untertitel einen Titel eines anderen Films nehmen?
Kannst du sagen, Avatar, The Shape of Water.
Und Alfonso Cuarón so Avatar Skull Island Hä? Avatar The Last Skywalker Leute, Leute, Leute, stopp, stopp, stopp Ruhig, wir kommen alle runter Jetzt wird's albern Überlegt euch, es gibt keine Namen mehr für Filme, es gibt keine Namen mehr für Filme. Aber wenn der dritte Teil nicht Avatar Endgame heisst, dann war es das bei mir. Avatar Endgame wäre mega geil. Der letzte Kampf. Ich sehe schon kommen, wieder ein bisschen lame. Die Grundstory wird ein bisschen lame. Guillermo del Toro, Entschuldigung. Shape of Water, und auch Shape of Water heisst, Shape of Water, das Flüstern des Wassers. Ja, ja, ich weiss. Das hat auch noch mal einen Untertitel.
Das heisst, eigentlich müsste es heißen Avatar, Avatar, the Shape of Water, das Flüstern des Wassers.
So heisst der Avatar.
Auf Skull Island. Aber das sind Klammern nur noch.
Auf Skull Island.
Resurrection.
Leute, Leute, Leute, ihr nehmt den, es kommt doch bestimmt auch vor, dass man so einen Film produziert, also du du ja vielleicht aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, man produziert sowas, steckt da viel Herzblut rein und am Ende merkt man, das ist einfach Schrott. Und dann nimmt man es auch nicht mehr ernst. Ja. Und dann sagt man, der ist einfach Quatsch geworden. Ja, das passiert ja auch. Ich meine, so ein Film ist ja wie ein Pfannkuchen. Du rührst ja den Teig an mit guten Intentionen, haust da gute Sachen rein, gibst dir Mühe und dann haust du den in die Pfanne und denkst, das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Also die Fett ist links und rechts und übergequollen und so und das kannst du ja niemandem zeigen, aber was sollst du machen? Ja, vor allem das Problem ist ja, dass du ja ein Jahr lang schreibst, dann irgendwann merkst, ah gut, die Deadline kommt immer näher, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, gut, ja gehen wir damit mal jetzt in Produktion. Dann gehst du in Produktion ein Jahr, merkst dabei auch, das Drehbuch hätte noch mal ein paar Monate vertragen können, ah shit, jetzt haben wir ja schon, ja gut, am Set kriegen wir schon hin, ah nein, Realität hits hard, Monsunregen, ah nein, das geht alles nicht, hier scheiße, Schauspieler hat am Set Herzinfarkt, müssen wir umcasten, ah nein, nein, nein, kack, Geld, Budget läuft aus, scheisse, und das schlechte Drehbuch kommt hinzu, naja gut, jetzt sind wir schon mittendrin, wir machen weiter.
Dann Postproduktion, kriegen wir alles im Schnitt gerettet, stellt sich heraus, im Schnitt kann man nichts retten, im Schnitt läuft uns auch die Zeit davon.
Überall regnet, scheisse, die Linse ist nass, die Hälfte ist das Team im Bild, der Boomer ist im Bild, die Boomer sind im Bild.
Nein, scheiße, scheiße, plus dieses nervige Drehbuch, was nicht zu Ende geschrieben wurde, am Anfang, wisst ihr noch, am Anfang, als ich meinte, das Drehbuch braucht noch eine Zeit, das ist auch noch ein Problem.
Was ist eigentlich aus der Figur Annika geworden? Die ist in den ersten zwei Rollen, wird die aufgebaut als beste Freundin. In Folge drei ist sie einfach nicht mehr da. Boomer stand immer genau vor denen im Bild. Und dann ist in zwei Wochen noch schon die Premiere. Scheiße, scheiße, ich brauche noch einen Anzug. Ich gehe jetzt mal aus dem Schnitt raus, weil ich muss noch kurz bei Karstadt Anzug kaufen. Tschüss, wir sehen uns noch auf der Premiere. Und dann hast du drei Jahre etwas gearbeitet. Die Deadlines der jeweiligen Phasen kamen immer viel zu schnell, es wird scheiße, alle im Team wissen, dass es scheiße ist, aber weil es halt ein Film ist, der jetzt aber auch bezahlt wird, erst jetzt von den Kinobesuchern, wurde dann trotzdem rausgebracht. Ja, das stimmt. Niemand sagt dir dann, ach nee, wir brauchen nicht veröffentlichen. Das heißt, es wird große Scheiße veröffentlicht. Und du musst ja bis zum letzten Punkt sagen, ja, der wird super, weil sonst gehen Leute schon in sich. Genau, und dann sitzt du da in Interviews lang, zehn Stunden Tage, sitzt in Interviews und sagst, was das für ein toller Film ist. Aber Tom Holland weiss eigentlich schon, dass es der Film ganz grauenhaft geworden ist. Deswegen sind das ja Schauspieler, weil die können ja in den Interviews so tun, als wäre es super. Deswegen castet man ja überhaupt erst Schauspieler,
damit die in der Marketingphase lügen können.
Ja, das hätte ich ja auch stehen können.
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Aber in der Marketingphase würde ich dann mit hochrotem Kopf auffallen.
Genau, Zähne klappern, Schüttelfrost, da am Set stehen, rumstehen und sich ausleuchten lassen, kann jeder, das ist kein Trottel.
Ich wäre total doof mit so einer blöden Kleidungswahl wie, ich stehe nicht hinter einem Film, Scheiß oder sowas, will ich dann in einem Interview sitzen.
Ja, oder du sagst immer, nicht gut geworden.
Entschuldigung?
Ich bin kein guter Schauspieler.
Und Tom Holland kann halt so tun, als wäre es gut.
Und ein Flickflack.
Und Tom Holland kann auch Flickflack tun.
Das ist halt auch cool.
Und gut tanzen kann er auch.
Das heißt, er kann dann sagen, und ist der Film gut geworden,
und sagt er, watch this.
Und dann macht er einen Flickflack und alle sagen, wow.
Wow.
Ist Wodaboutism aber wow. Are you from Holland or is it Netherlands? Ah, egal. Tom Netherlands. Thomas Netherlands. Wenn der Mutter wütend ist, dann sagt er, Thomas Rodolphus Netherlands, the Great Republic of Netherlands. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, da weiss man schon. Ja, aber wenn er geblitzt wurde, kriegt er auch direkt dann, weil ich kriege dann immer an Stefan Michael-Tietz adressierte Briefe und er kriegt dann Thomas Netherlands III und weiss direkt, oh shit, you can call me Holland, it's okay. Ich wurde in Cockney geblitzt. Briten, ey. Ah, Briten. Man, ja, oh, da können ich jetzt wieder anfangen, ey. Wenn ich da einmal losgelassen werde, dann nöhe ich nicht mehr auf. Lass uns jetzt hier lieber einen Punkt machen, sonst rast ich wieder aus. Leute, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche. Haut rein. Kommt gut durch die Woche mal durch. Kommt gut durch die Woche. Nach Mittwoch ist ja fast Wochenende. Dann ist noch Sonnnerstag und Freitag, dann habt ihr auch die Woche schon wieder rumbekommen. Dann ist es auch wieder. Dann kommen wir auch schon wieder rum. Am Samstag kommen wir schon wieder vorbei.
Vollkommen am Samstag raus, also ist noch eine Weile bis Wochenende, aber macht's gut, haut rein, wir verabschieden uns und sehen uns hoffentlich bald wieder, wenn es wieder heisst.
Hallo.
DPU, hallo, ich bin Stefan und der andere. Haut rein, macht's gut, ciao.